hi my name is Mona theme and I'm
currently a junior and electrical
engineering and computer science my work
broadly goes over automated fake news
detection more specifically automated
factory fication given some claim like
did Barack Obama win the 2016 election
I provide a probability of how much this
claim is true or how much it may be
false if you think about how you may do
this you would think okay given some
claim which evidences do I have to
support or refute this claim so I've
created a search engine that given some
query retrieves all possible evidences
and arteries how much these evidences
agree or disagree with this claim now
once you have a list of evidences that
support or refute this claim and you
know how much they support refute it you
may want to also figure out how credible
is each speaker because for example one
adversary may want to flood the internet
with a few dozen small websites and that
doesn't mean that this is as credible as
say for example and established
journalism like the New York Times
because of this we finally take these
evidences and we know how much they
agree in disagree and we wait these by
who's speaking and how much credibility
do they have finally we can return this
weighted sum over who's speaking how
much credibility they have and what are
they saying it's more specifically I'm
working on the first bucket pipeline
which is evidence selection given some
query I returned a list of sorted
documents representing how relevant each
claim is and what number the document is
in that position one way to think about
this is then basically building Google
search you type in some query and you
get a list of sorted documents
Google search has a 56% chance of
showing you what you want to see as the
first result on the list for the search
engine I've built I have a 79 percent
chance of showing you the result you
wanna see as the first result on the
list this means that we have more
information - more accurate fake news
assessment check out our demo on factor
app and I'm happy to discuss this more
thank you